in my past life as a soccer coach once
you win a national championship
everybody wants to come play for you
really not true once you pay them 25 000
a year in scholarships everybody wants
to come play for you and parents would
always come to me and they'd say
okay uh my son or my daughter wants to
come play at your university what is it
that we have to do um you know what are
you looking for and being the socratic
professor that i am well what does your
son or daughter do what do they do
really well that we'd be interested in
and typically their answers are well
they've got great vision they're really
good they can see the entire field or my
daughter is the fastest player there's
nobody that can beat her or my son's got
a great left foot or really really great
in the air and can hit every ball
like yeah
not bad
but to be quite honest with you those
are the last things i'm looking for the
most important thing
self-confidence
without that skill and i use the word
skill intentionally without that skill
we are useless as a soccer player
because when you lose sight or belief in
yourself
we're done for
i use the definition of self-confidence
to be the ability or the belief
to believe in yourself to to accomplish
any task no matter the odds no matter
the difficulty no matter the adversity
the belief that you can accomplish it
self-confidence some are using a great i
don't have it i'm so shy i'll never do
good
and you start to drag all the way down
here
but i use the word skill because
i believe it can be trained and i'll
show you a couple of ways in which we do
hopefully i won't run out of time i
don't use any slides because my speech
always goes here here or here so we'll
see which way we get to
the easiest way to build self-confidence
there's no magic button i can't say hey
this plane is going down who can fly it
put your hand up i can i'm confident
repetition repetition repetition
right what does malcolm gladwell call it
uh the ten thousand hour rule there's no
magic button i recruited a goalie from
columbia south america one year uh big
tall six foot three man
uh you know he had hands like stone i
thought he was like flipper every time i
throw him the ball down down onto the
ground i was like oh my god we're in
trouble
simple solution get to the wall kick a
ball against the wall and catch it kick
the ball against the wall and catch it
his goal was 350 a day for eight months
he came back
his hands were calloused the moisture on
his hands were literally gone he is now
playing in europe magic no repetition
repetition repetition
the problem is we expect to be
self-confident but we can't be unless
the skill or the task we're doing is not
novel is not new to us
we want to be in a situation where we've
created we've had so much pressure in
that and what i mean because pressure
builds diamonds we want to be in a
situation where
hey i've done this a thousand times
i did my speech and i practiced in front
of the mirror
hey i'm sounding good and then i read in
front of my kids and my men and my wife
it's like oh my gosh i got a little
nervous then i get in front of the
glengool oh my goodness i'm a little
more nervous
by the time i get to the acg where 2500
people can't say anymore right 2500
people
where 2500 people are there i won't have
a single ounce of nervousness because of
my ability to practice
right over and over and over again the
problem with repetition is
how many of us bail after the first bit
of failure how many of us fail after the
first bit of adversity edison was on
that video
and depends who you ask there's anywhere
from 1 000 to 10 000 tries to build that
light bulb
one thousand to ten thousand jk rowling
should be on that video the only
publisher she took her harry potter book
to
i believe the number was 12 or 13. i
don't i'm pretty confident but after two
or three no's i'd be like dang it after
six or seven i'm like maybe not
definitely after nine or ten i'd be
looking to be a soccer coach or
something else beside an author
right i mean 12 times somebody said no
but
practice practice practice and do not
accept failure maybe it shouldn't be
repetition maybe the answer should be
persistence
because we all repeat something but very
few of us really will persist
so that's one way to build
self-confidence
get out there do what you want to do and
accept no do not accept no
the other one is self-talk we all have a
self-talk tape that plays in our head
anybody go shopping and put on a pair of
pants this week if you're a woman the
first thing that always comes damn i
look fat in these pants
and if you're a man it's the opposite oh
god i have no muscle i'm so flabby right
we all have this tape that plays in our
head as a student if they asked me the
question it was like oh gee please the
police professor don't pick me i don't
know the answer don't i look down
right if you're in the when i let me
tell you something and the vp of
business admin is here so i shouldn't
repeat this but when they hired me as an
athletic director i sat in an
architect's meeting and i am about as
dumb as a post when it comes to anything
to do with numbers and angles and
they're like the fundiblator valve of
the uh architectural
there there is what do you think uh dr
joseph
uh let me look into that for you and get
back to you
right
i was saying oh god god don't please
don't ask me please don't ask me we all
have this negative self-talk that goes
in our head
guess what
there's enough people that are telling
us we can't do it that we're not good
enough
why do we want to tell ourselves that
we know for a fact that thoughts
influence actions we saw it there with
the um with the video sheldon dr levy
showed right we know that our thoughts
influence actions why do we want to say
that negative self-talk to ourselves
we need to get our own self-affirmations
muhammad ali what was his
self-affirmation
i am the
greatest
who else is going to tell you there need
to be quiet moments in your bedroom
quiet moments when you're brushing your
teeth that we need to reaffirm
i am the captain of my ship and the
master of my fate
that is my affirmation i came from a
school of 1 000 people i lived in a town
of 1 000 people for 15 years there's no
reason that i should be in charge of an
athletic department building maple leaf
gardens
but i am the captain of my ship and the
master of my fate
if i don't say it if i don't believe it
no one else will
how do you build self-confidence
get away from the people who will tear
you down
there's enough of that muhammad ali
i am the greatest there is no one better
than me it's a difference between hubris
and ego
and false pride
it's just reminding yourself in quiet
silent moments i put it down on the list
it's right beside my mirror
right about all the things that make me
who i am because i make enough mistakes
and the newspapers will recognize it and
people around me will recognize it and
they'll tear me down
and pretty soon i'll begin to believe it
there was a time when my confidence was
really low
there's a time when i took this job when
i came from iowa
i
don't know if i could do it i had to
bring out my self-confidence letter a
letter i wrote to myself when i was
feeling good ivan congratulations on
getting your phd before 40.
congratu i am 40 under
congratulations on winning a national
championship good job on raising three
good kids and marrying the right woman i
wrote a letter to myself
it was my own brag sheet
my own letter about the things i was
proud of
because there are moments and we'll all
experience them in our career
in our life and our job hunting and our
relationships when we are not feeling
good about who and what and where we are
and i had to bring out that letter and
read it time and time again for a period
of about two weeks
to weather me through that storm
it was important
stop the self-talk the negative
self-talk if you'll watch you'll see
some athletes they'll have a little
bandage or a little
brand around them lance armstrong's a
perfect one
what's his self-affirmation livestrong
isn't a brand it was to remind him of
who he was live strong
then it became a brand he would move
that from one arm to the next arm when
doubt and fear came into his mind live
strong put it on there let's go
we'll all have it
replace it
two ways to build self-confidence
worried about my time i'm gonna tell you
of one way that you can build
self-confidence in others
we are coaches and educators
we are teachers we are people who will
create value in the world and in doing
that we are critical by the nature of
what we do i'm a i'm a coach i want you
to score a goal ball went over high dang
it the ball went high thank you coach i
know that feedback tells me that so what
do we do i need you to put your elbow or
here i need you to put your knee over
the ball i need to follow through boom
land good eight notice i never made it
as a
professional what can we do
we fix mistakes when i'm fixing that
mistake johnny this is terrible you need
to bend your knee you need to do this
this what have i done to johnny's
self-confidence
bend your knee think of this do this
next thing you know johnny's crushed
ignore what johnny does wrong and find
bob or sally or freda over here great
goal frida i loved how you kept your
knee low you followed through and you
landed like this great job
johnny
great
johnny's not demoralized his confidence
isn't shot and what i've done is i've
built up frida's imagine how we could
change the way we parented kids instead
of get that glass off the counter what's
wrong with you
if we catch them while they're good
great job great job thank you alice for
taking your glass to the counter it
sounds simple but we forget about it or
as educators or somebody as a team if we
manage to praise the positive behavior
that we wanted to reinforce
we forget it sounds so simple catch them
when they're good
we forget it it's simple here's what
they did there was a study in kansas
that did this they did video and we all
do video and we showed the video of them
doing the run of the play uh this goal
happened because the basket wasn't
protected we didn't rotate here right we
needed to do this and then to cover the
slot and
if that's the baseline improvement of
the kansas state team went like this
then
they said they ignored all of that and
they just showed them the times they did
it right
the times they did it perfect that
presented no goals spoke to the same
points improvement went like that
it changed and revolutionized the way we
as coaches interact with our student
athletes
we can apply that to the business world
we can apply that to our student group
works we can apply that to our
management teams easily
catch them when they're good
last and certainly not least
my son is really good at this
self-confident people interpret feedback
the way they choose to i asked my son
who is by the far
terrible terrible athlete gets it from
his dad
the games they win five nights how was
the game oh great i scored three goals i
got two assists i'm like i did not see
him touch the puck
but he has his own perception of how he
did
i love it
right i'm not i'm that guy i'm like i
remember was taking my there's when i
met my wife it was in the comments uh
polly i'd like to would you like to go
to the movies ladies
and she goes she goes um no i i
i ask her again because i think that she
just hasn't seen me in the right light
maybe that's not the wrong shirt on
right because i'm interpreting that the
way i want to interpret it
finally i asked her again she actually
gave me this one comment right or she
sent it to her friend because that's the
way you did it back then uh he would not
she wouldn't date you unless it was the
last person on earth that hell was
freezing over there was a small chance
we had to save the planet earth some
people's like there's no chance i'm like
you're saying there's a
chance right
because that's how i'm going to
interpret it
if i could give you one thing to take
from this it is
no one will believe in you unless you do
listen to the words of that video here's
to the crazy ones the misfits the rebels
the troublemakers
the round pegs and the square holes
we're supposed to be different folks
and when people look at us
believe in yourself
thank you